elles sont arrivés par la route cette
locomotive à vapeur de 1880 était dans
la sarthe après avoir longtemps séjourné
en touraine et celle ci construite en
1905 provient d'une association basée
près de lyon c'est pas tous les jours
deux locomotives à vapeur qui arrive
donc sont pas en état de fonctionnement
mais on va pouvoir exposé au musée
présente au public la dernière
locomotive qui arrivent et sans vapeur
sans 1982
la 0,20 et lebron est une ancêtre qu'il
nécessiterait de gros travaux pour
pouvoir rouler à nouveau
elle est la propriété de deux membres de
l'association pithiverais nhs qui l'ont
acquise pour transmettre son histoire au
public
j'ai une machine caractéristiques de
chantier donc à la servir à reconstruire
des villes des ponts tout un tas de
choses et elle a fini sa carrière dans
une balade tiers
du côté de dreux c'est un patrimoine
historique qui doit être visible pour
moi
le partage est l'essence même de
l'association qui gère le musée des
transports du pithiviers elle est
spécialisée dans les machines évoluant
sur les rails de 60 cm d'écartement elle
dispose désormais d'une dizaine de
locomotive à vapeur dont la plus vieille
de france datant de 1870 on va dire
qu'on possède ici dans le loiret dans
notre musée et depuis les deux plus
vieilles locomotives à votre 60 d'europe
et celle ci celle ci s'est plu
sentimental plus symbolique puisque
c'est une machine de 1905 qui arrivait à
pithiviers en 1921 et qui est parti en
un témoin de l'existence de la voie
ferrée pithiviers toury sur laquelle
elle a tracté des récolte de betteraves
pendant plus de 40 ans les deux
locomotives devait être visible au début
de l'été après plusieurs semaines de
toilettage